[Music]
douchebag hunting season you know no one
has his number what are you up to these
days
beginning the odds this is the team I
could work with actually I would rather
if you freshing you actually know what
you're doing down there yeah that's what
she said
Hey Wow like always the dough you're my
eyes in the sky
sanic age recollection family me what
you want I can put you and running back
huh
I read between the lines kick some ass
get the girl and try to look dope why
you do it
drop the second Superfly what
three you wanted in the dark you could
have just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world
just fallen into the hands of four very
dangerous gas we need someone who can
move like them quite like them it's time
to be patriot there are no more Patriots
just rebel and tyrants so which are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team all right it comes Red Bulls
poster child I'm not gonna have clowns
watch my back who would you trust a good
the extreme Riley completely insane Oh
what you want I got what you need
now that's a team I can work with
freshing you actually know what you're
doing down there yeah that's what she
said Wow
these case of yours are the real kind of
trouble you have no idea what you're up
against
whatever it is you're looking for you're
gonna come up short this is mean you're
not making me breakfast in the water
we're willing to die you keep the world
safe how about you I'll live for this
I guess we're on the same team now you
ready to have some fun
I go long I'll go
let me simplify boy kick some ass get
the girl and try to look dope why are
you doing
Danah feels good to be back you know
they say the world is safer than has
ever been in the history of civilization
do you feel safer today than you did
yesterday I know I don't
the world has changed war we're fighting
today
needs a different kind of soldier
we need people with the skills and the
attitude way
to take on threats we don't even know
exist
we need someone who can walk into a
tornado and come out the other side like
it was a damn gentle breeze it's one in
the back you could have just asked let
me simplify for you kick some ass
and try to look dope why are you doing
I could definitely make that work
guns girls global domination
and the cage is back
hey there's Nikki jam and I can't wait
to see all my fans in Mexico to watch
the world premiere of Triple X coming
out on January the 5th gotta see you
gotta check it out this is Nicky Jam
well I heard this is a perfect place to
disappear he caused us to gossip the
place is right 22 and a half
how you gonna doing a hat I'm gonna tell
okay 22 and a half I like you stop man
this is a team like a work kick some an
get the girl and track can look dope why
are you doing
hi Liam wave
I live for this
[Applause]
I live for this the world is at war we
need a different kind of soldier
let's do this great have some fun
dan it feels good to be back the world
is that parable the country needs you
mr. cage here we go again
here I have some fun I go along
Oh
dan it feels good to be back
guns girls global domination and a cages
back this is mean you're not making me
breakfast in the law a device that
controls every satellite in the world
has fallen into the wrong hands the
world needs saving
but somehow we do
it's good to be back the world is at
peril we need people with the skills
down on the ground and the attitude
that's why two blinks now that's a team
like a work with good good the extreme
Wow completely instead you ready to have
some fun I go look I'll go
dan it feels good to be back
sander cage this is crazy
dan it feels good to be
[Music]
dan it feels good to be back
you ready to have some fun
dan I feels good to be back
dan it feels good to be back
dan it feels good to be back
dan it feels good to be back
dan it feels good to be back
dan it feels good to be back
whatever it is you're here for you can
come up short
dan it feels good to be back
well I heard this is a perfect place to
disappear for a couple of days he got
the Tsukasa The Price is Right
dan it feels good to be
you